i do not want these people to get away
with this
and no one should ever literally ever
had to experience what me and my
girlfriend is now going through i
couldn't agree more
i do not want you to get away with this
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in love
and my afro was picky
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah welcome
back to my channel hope you guys are
welcome inshallah a video was sent to me
and i want to get straight into it it's
a from a youtuber called a pretty boy
freddle
well pretty boy my brother look who call
your brother
boy boy boy boy
freddle became a ugly boyfriend
with his attitude you know with the
stuff that he said now what's really
ironic is that this is the same guy
pretty boy fredo i'm going to call him
pretty boy yeah
uh so this pretty boy he got a bit upset
because a couple of months ago he was
racially profiled himself
while going down the elevator in his
apartment with his dog
by a caucasian man before we get into
that though let's watch
what he's saying i just having a chat
with this person um
online let's see what he has to say
let's see what's happened to you
sweetheart i got my shirt off
what are you doing you just smell his
hand why are you smelling your hair man
[ __ ] i love these your mama's mouth
[ __ ] how about what
what this thing might be a terrorist
thought of it
hold on it might be a terrorist
i want to work like hold on
this [ __ ]
now pretty boy if you're listening to
the most like you're gonna be watching
this as well now we could have give you
the benefit of that because you made a
tweet saying you know what
i didn't know what allah meant and that
allah spoke to my cross muslim friend
so he kind of used that card where a lot
of people use and say you know i'm not i
don't
i'm not racist towards black people i've
got black friends so maybe who's that
kind of you know
has a close muslim friend so you have a
close muslim friend
but this close muslim friend recently
tells you about
you know what allah means etc now what
gives you away
is that you when you hear the word allah
and you're talking disrespectfully yeah
because i just see look at you i just
i'll be honest with you yeah sadly we
live in today's time where
youtubers are just coming and trying to
make content and trying to look cool and
trying to use words like you know
yeah yeah you're laughing you don't i'm
being honest i don't know what you
genuinely have to offer you know except
from entertainment
you know there is nothing in substance
because all you're doing is using the n
word continuously
repeatedly like a broken record and i'm
not trying to be disrespectful i'm
trying to get a point across so i want
you to really hear me out here
because as much as um i i'm gonna tell
you why i'm really annoyed as well which
i'm sure you're not a muslim
um but you're there you're just trying
to make content or you're just talking
for the sake of it and then the guy says
um allah and then you start insulting
god's name yeah now our religion teaches
that when somebody insults god allah
we do not insult them back or their gods
back yeah and then when you connect
allah to terrorists so you do know what
you're talking about you don't know
muslims don't get it don't get it you
know what's stupid here
yeah so don't just change your tone
um or voice just because now
it's been caught on camera now let's
quickly move on because there's
something really ironic that happens
with pretty boy freddo now let's watch
this
in this very video he's talking about
being racially profile
now i'm one what he said about our
god i want to express myself
via pretty boy's pretty boy
freddo's mouth so i want you to listen
to pretty boy freddo
and it's as if ali is talking in the
sense of
um he's suffered islamophobia let's
let's put instead of
racially being profiled he's been uh
he's suffered islamophobia yeah
okay and look what he says you're gonna
get one what i'm about to say here god
let's let's watch it last friday i was
disrespected in a manner
that i could never imagine now
two days ago or when your every video
came out
we as the muslim community 1.8 billion
of us
were disrespected in a way you couldn't
imagine
i'm using your boy i'm using your own
words pretty boy
let's carry on not only was i racially
slurred
racially slandered but i was
disrespected
not was i not only was i suffered
islamophobia
and my god was insulted
i was disrespected as a muslim
from your words i'm not changing a few
words here pretty boyfried in a way that
i would never want
to happen to someone ever in a way
as a muslim i wouldn't want anybody
to go through that be drew or a
christian or whatever faith you might
follow
so i'm using pretty boy's words yeah
friday i was racially slandered i was
racially slurred by this caucasian male
when i was going up the elevator
when this video came out i suffered
islamophobia
by this individual called
pretty boy fredo yes
i'm using your words how you feel i'm
using it back i'm using the same words
i'm trying to get a point across you i'm
sure you're getting the point in that
moment i was not expecting this guy to
call me a [ __ ] and call me all these
different names
in that moment when i watched a video i
wasn't expecting a black man like
yourself
who suffers racism whose ancestors have
gone through enslavement
and all kind of trauma to say something
like that
not from a black man i wasn't expecting
that
i wasn't expecting that from you freddo
be cursing at me and be aggressive with
me i was not expecting that i pulled my
phone out
at the very literally the very last
seconds of this gold guy going off now
i took my screen recorder out and
recorded what you said immediately now
of course when i put the phone up he's
not gonna be doing the same thing
he's gonna change his whole manual he's
not gonna when i did do that and a lot
of people did that
now he's not gonna be doing the same
thing for the boy changed his tone and
made a tweet and a disclaimer
that he didn't no really
now you're accusing a caucasian man that
called you the n-word and all this kind
of
every right to be upset damn right and i
stand against
racism and a lot of people know that
so you got your phone out and he was
very enraged and angry
well when the same thing happened by
your followers or some people that
follow you
yeah which i would encourage everyone
not to watch as muslims because your
stuff
islamically is not correct for us you
can do it whatever you like
you change your tone as well just as
that caucasian man you claim changes
tone
you change your tone isn't it ironic
pretty boy freddo let's carry on
he's not gonna be the same of course
isn't that true that my dog was snapping
at people come on man start with the
[ __ ] dog you see a young black [ __ ]
with a pibble
simple you see a young black [ __ ] with
a pit bull but you didn't know who i was
you didn't know the type of person that
i truly was i was racial profile
so you claim a caucasian man saw a young
black boy with a pit bull and he thought
you know what
he racially profiled this guy probably a
gangster probably a drug dealer
probably a thief or god knows what you
know but he didn't know that
you're not you're none of them yeah you
are a rude person
yeah you did say something some phobic
stuff well
did you not do the same thing to that
guy who you saw he looked a bit like a
muslim
and he said a few words he said allah
and of allah you've made him a terrorist
you just insulted god you went on a mad
one isn't it ironic you went through
this very same thing and you're making
another person go through it
it's in the hypocritical thread reflect
upon what i'm trying to say
let's we've got a few more videos and
then we're going to be done
i do not want these people to get away
with this and no one should ever
literally ever have to experience what
me and my girlfriend is now going
through
i couldn't agree more i do not want you
to get away with this
i do not want anybody to get away with
this
because your words have consequences
people
die yes die an australian woman
muslim woman was attacked in a
restaurant a pregnant woman
in the united kingdom where i live a
woman a pregnant muslim woman was kicked
and lost her child because of people
like your remarks
who make these comments and then we like
my wife
has to go and i i have to accompany her
to places she goes because i fear that
she may be attacked
and our sisters muslim women get in the
hijab from top their head
to being shot down in mosques 51
dead slaughtered massacred by a maniac
why because if an islamophobe watches
your video and thinks you know what
as a black community these guys don't
even like the muslims
they may use that now let's watch a
video of the interaction that he had
that really enraged him
so i was going up the elevators and what
did you do and what did you do
i said step back i said that because of
my dog i said let me go by myself just
hurry though
and get out of the way anything else you
want to say no you don't never profile
someone else again
never do that again you are disgusting
you are disgusting
you are disgusting that you
every instance that caused pretty boy
freddo
to get upset and angry and it's such a
shame pretty boyfriend
and i genuinely hope you are sorry not
because you're going to lose followers
and subscribers or something like that
but you're genuinely sorry because you
went through something similar in a
different way
and we hope you understand that how
disgusting
what you said was um and that we hope
you can at least learn as a muslim
myself
i can say i forgive you because indeed
allah tells us it's better to forgive
we are just muslims who worship god
alone and we try to abide by his laws
if you want to know more about islam um
you're a youtuber i can send you some
material if you do that's up to you
like you don't have to but i just want
you to know and understand
that it wasn't right and it's
hypocritical i'm sure you know that
and we hope you are genuinely sorry and
hope you will learn a lesson from this
i've got nothing animosity towards you
it's just sad to see
but if you have any questions want to
get in contact with me or anybody else
you need some material understand islam
and muslims more
we're here to help you still no hard
feelings
till next time assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh
share this with your friends and family
goodbye